le duc manh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au revoir pas de feuillets de vote à la sortie
pas de roberto mi fu chi dit sur le site
ne pas avoir
Je dis deux mots traduit à moitié quelqu'un
musique qui, enfant, sur lady of one
campano était chez moi que personne ne savait
et juste ces feuilles de métal j'ai fermé le
yeux et j'ai l'impression d'entendre mieux
maintenant d'une chaleur quitte la famille
il transmet ce que je dois vous dire que je ressens
ma famille à la maison
Je pense que le cinéma c'est la famille et qu'il
slogan mais bref si ce sable
décalogue chaque grain est important mais
vous le savez bien merci a tous
organisateurs et matthew matthew est celui qui
vous a fait confiance pour auditionner le courage
mais ce n'est pas assez je pense que c'est assez et ça nous fait
sucer c'est quoi dire qu'ils sont évalués à
aimé aussi l'état de montée du corps mince
lire un post it sur l'occupation de
gobbato venini un raid de manson ha
enlevé dans les toilettes de rome ou une douzaine de
cri de votre série al sammartino
criminel aide sporta
majeures acquittées et sociales
détails combat garonne puissance si
fermer les jeux pour le moment le seul
frisson secoue l'équipe faites le moi savoir
je me réfère